the Internet president is Donald Trump
who hosts the social media summit at the
White House I had the honor of being
invited to it you walk into the foyer of
the White House I mean famous Bentall
Hollywood movies it's you know from the
time of Lincoln and they're huge memes
print it out on boards painting in the
grand foyer of the White House tape like
this is this is the world I've been
begging for my entire career
you walk around look there's a mean and
there's a game of Thrones meme and it
they're all bear likes hanging inside of
the most sacred house in America people
will gravitate towards something
authentic more than ever today and it's
because we've been trained to do this
based on what we like on social media
the authenticity that we see into
people's lives and we now have access
into everyone's life people can figure
out what Dave Rubin likes these people
can follow you on social media and see
the things about you and I yeah and see
what you love and what you hate and they
can tell if you're an authentic person
and we are now demanding that inside of
our politicians and like it or not
that's part of the reason why people
just adore the president United States
right now is because there's no lying
with him you're gonna hear his
unvarnished opinions regardless of
whether you love them or not you're
going to see directly inside of his
brain and what's going on and you're
gonna find that out through his social
media and through Twitter and that's
what in dere's so many Americans to that
we've been trained to want that alright
so how the hell does Trump understand
all this stuff I have asked a million
guests this everyone has their own
theory but how does the Trump get the
meme Wars the edge lords the trolls the
Russians the whole damn thing how does
Trump get it
I think you've a little insight maybe
into what he's thinking or you've been
around him enough and the turning point
world Trump has always been a creature
of the media he's always very much
understood media and every era that he's
lived in from the 70s 80s 90s to today
he's understood media and how people
consume information where is the
audience and he's always understood
audience
now we have to ask yourself if you're
talking about the modern media landscape
what is a media company immediate
companies were the audience's and Trump
has very elegantly navigated to the
place where the audience is every single
iteration of his career and it's been
very very special to watch how the guy
at 70 years old has just mastered the
meme wars and just mastered the art of
social media and a new generation of
kids that's where they are that's where
they're getting their information do you
think the world was just waiting for
someone like him like it didn't actually
have to be him but that because of
everything you're talking about in the
way that things have changed and we
watch mainstream media crumble and the
internet rise and all that but it was
gonna be somebody to do this reckoning
and he just happened to be the guy or do
you think that that really is unique
about him the way he the lens that he
used the world because of the way he
survived media over decades and all that
yeah I think we're living in the Golden
Age of memes and politics and Trump has
brought that about and the world was
waiting for someone to create the diad
in the force that was the president I'm
gonna see how many more stories you can
force in here see force in here I love
what you just did there Dave you the
world was waiting for the the internet
president right the president who fully
understood the internet and brought it
with him to the White House and Barack
Obama bringing in YouTube celebrities
that's one thing but Barack Obama was
not the internet president not at all
the Internet president is Donald Trump
who hosts the social media summit at the
White House I had the honor of being
invited to it you walk into the foyer of
the White House I mean famous Bentall
Hollywood movies it's just you know from
the time of Lincoln and there are huge
memes printed out on boards painting in
the grand foyer of the White House made
like this is this is the world I've been
begging for my entire career
you walk around look there's a mean and
there's a game of Thrones meme and it
they're all bare like
inside of the most sacred house in
America right the most cherished and
valuable piece of real estate in the
country is the White House one of those
recognizable places on planet Earth is
the White House and here are memes
hanging inside of the grand foyer of the
White House this is actually the
Internet president I think it's really
fundamental that Trump gets audience he
understands where an audience is and
right now today there has been a dynamic
shift in where people actually are and
where people are are platforms and where
they want to get their information or
platforms and from influencers and Trump
that's the biggest influence are out
there so the last time that we actually
saw each other in person was at the
turning-point student action summit
about a week before Christmas couple
days before Christmas I spoke that
morning you you you were sort of the
emcee of the whole thing right you're
shooting t-shirts into the crowd and
you're getting everybody going but you
didn't warm up the crowd for me that
morning well what you were doing that
Saturday morning I wasn't gonna bring
this up I don't know what happened I did
okay that's not even the boy I did just
find the point is that I spoke in the
morning and then and then Trump spoke
later in the afternoon and it was and
then when he spoke he was the first time
that I ever ever heard him speak live
and and it did help crystallize one
thing for me which is how the media
takes an hour and a half speech that he
gives and how they really extrapolate
whatever they want out of it because
there's a moment that I'm sure you
remember where Trump gets up there he
goes he goes I know more about windmills
than anybody my whole life and then he
goes on this riff about Windows now
obviously he doesn't know more about
windmills and everybody obviously he's
not studying windmills but he makes some
interesting points about how they build
windmills and all of this other stuff
but then I saw it happen so he does the
speech and he sort of basically like a
comic and he's work in the room and he
kind of goes off script and then comes
back but then it was the next part and
this is where I really had all kind of
crystallized for me was then later that
afternoon what do I see of course Vox
media matters the rest of it with all of
their headlines Donald Trump claims he
knows more about windmills than anybody
Donald Trump claims he studied windmills
is all life
and it's like did he say that he did is
that in context
do you understand sarcasm no yes and
it's like when you when you really see
it that way it did shift the whole thing
for me to actually be there and then see
the headlines yes there is such a thing
as sarcasm humor still in the world it's
not literate it's not literal literal
right i'ma not both actually yeah but a
good meme is something that takes it
that is funny
that uses humor or uses pop culture to
connote a greater truth about the world
around us and Donald Trump speaks and
memes so what a lot of people I don't
think understand yeah is that this arrow
was actually made for him when Donald
Trump looks Hillary Clinton in the eye
and goes because you'd be in jail that's
like an impact fought me that was a mean
right like that was one of the most
memorable maybe perhaps the most
memorable if you play it on a big screen
to an audience which I do regularly the
most memorable moment in 2016 and that
was Trump just speaking at a meme sure
sentences understandable dialogue joke
right sarcasm but hitting a deeper truth
and that's the way the President speaks
and the hyper literal perpetually
wanting to be offended corporate media
that exists today they don't they don't
get them but at their peril because
Trump is speaking the way that the
Internet speaks and the way that
consumers speak and the way that the
audiences of the future speak and the
audiences of the future want to get
their information from memes I give this
speech around the country tens of
thousands of students around the country
I speak to every single year and it's a
huge privilege of mine to do that but I
ask them with regularity where would you
prefer to get your information raise
your hand if you want to get your
information from a meme if you would
prefer it in that form and thousands of
hands go I'm telling you Dave thousands
of hands go up from the students I take
a cell phone out of my pocket I do this
thought prompt this thought test all the
time take a cell phone out of my pocket
put on the table and I say this cell
phone is yours it's free you can get it
free of charge one rule locked it coded
in to the actual iPhone brand-new is
that you can only download
one app to get your news and information
from what happened you downloaded I
asked kids this doesn't matter if it's
fifty kids in a small room or 500 kids
or 5,000 kids it's always the same I'm
guessing the answer is Twitter right
don't tell me it's tick tock and I'm
gonna jump it it's a mix a lot of
instagrams I would say probably eight
out of ten is an Instagram that's not
again these are school-aged kids their
school-aged kids eight out of ten as an
Instagram you always have your outliers
we'll say reddit it's maybe you know
very rarely about Facebook
you get YouTube a lot of youtubes and
some Twitter's it kind of depends on the
diet of the students sure here's
something that never ever ever said ever
MSNBC yeah
CNN well CNN when I give a speech to
college kids CNN sometimes I say
something about CNN not to be funny I'm
like no CNN is one channel and and they
laugh when I say CNN as it backs a bunch
it's so excited to them you know I don't
think it's even partisan Dave I they
they don't say Fox News either they want
to get their information from and I'm
just gonna be complimentary here you
from a decentralized non corporate
influencer who is going to bring them
the information that they trust you they
trust guys like me they trust
influencers they want we are the new
nightly news anchors the memes are our
new news program right and the new
broadcast network are these platforms
that they can follow us on and see more
of a dimensionality of us and the world
around them and that's how they prefer
to get their information if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell